and the thing is why is it that when
when a woman tells a man this is what I
want the men got to listen but when the
man is saying this is what I want to be
like no no no no no no no no no no I
don't think we were saying that we don't
accept I just don't give up I don't I
don't care she's like it's not like
everybody is not the only man in this
world like I think in this way cool like
you're gonna find is 20 years old girl
who can give free child and whatever
like we are sitting there we are setting
that we just think in a different way
which is a completely different thing
who like as I like a six foot guy and
you are setting it I'm fine with you
getting taken out at 20 years old girl